welcome to this video playing tennis
master DeMarcus no one named there okay
I cannot go if I've what should I do
yeah Sicilian probably okay going for
some clothes so you know g4 it's funny
it's not that bad actually can can do
that quite often if you right place with
g3 quite often you get to a situation
where you yeah you weigh almost wish
that you have played g4 because you
played g3 g4 later so he's expanding
rapidly rapidly on the Kings side hmm
okay maybe I can can i irritate a little
bit down for Knight f6 naija form and so
he right 'if i have no fe5 special tool
Wow okay Bishop g5 screen g-form
hmm quite strange this whole thing
hmm yeah okay I have to check right my
night was hanging on g7 have known I g4
fancy stuff like that actually I have
some kind of a bit skeptical about my
position yet looks I don't know looks a
bit strange but I cannot really i don't
see a refutation yeah this this kind of
thing yeah might might be the might be
the issue but ok um I have 94 and then
he goes age three
porn Hanks only six
mm-hmm can also always insert insert be
for him okay take first think later age
three and now what night back to I can
also play Knight d2 e five yeah maybe
takes knight takes Bishop f4 i have e 5
is 93 it's really not working at all but
okay but okay it's still reasonably
murky this this whole position
think even night texts six is playable I
don't really have a good reply to that
that's hauler it's a whole bunch of
smoke and smokes and mirrors I think
it's there it's the way is the
expression for that
I think you can really just take it ya
can just take it Kim I was thinking e5
but night of 3 is really the issue of
them I'm any Bishop e7 thing like to get
check there on the diagonal would be
brilliant I've got Bishop default check
you but don't really see how to get them
and probably I cannot it's a simple
problem I don't see anything because
there is nothing before 92 doesn't help
I but maybe maybe you can take it six
however man but ok cannot worry about
those things yeah I was thinking maybe I
can just I can just play this position
oh oh man that's bad ok ok don't I don't
keep this this is the big thing I can
take me to where don't keep it if I
would keep the pawn I mean it's repaid
three pawns ok push him let's potion
again push him for Bishop g7
yes Bishop f6 this mayor came maybe this
and then d5 this may be making some kind
of okay now a half Bishop Bishop age 60
pages sex with full-scale swindling mode
unfortunately in a position where this
little to swindle on and say little
chances little chances for a swindle
going them
you
as king is still a little bit a little
bit shaky but it's really far beyond
serious no more freely Jeff
the only chance why you can continue
here is just that his King yeah this
it's a bit a bit iffy the King position
but ok he will win this um even Bishop
e6 might be on no okay time warning
chick this is just a trade unfortunately
but maybe here rook takes g4 said little
idea
look aged three a little idea again not
not really he's not screwing it up at
least I don't see anything check I look
one be serviced meter check okay charmed
lad was risen only just not not very
good but it's that seems kind of okay
here and that was curious em but f five
is good g5 is also a good move but that
that seemed fine yeah it's just like
it's it's it's kind of complicated but
it's not working really he has a good
good defensive position and again here I
am this is this I'm just fishing here
and i can easily i could have designed
him yeah it's not working as simple as
that so that means i have to play some
normal move here which is certainly
possible there are many moves um for
example what is what is a good movie m97
maybe 97 96 yeah something like that
this is not so great yeah my night is
not really great in terms of squares I
can also try this just being ready for
Knight f6 now it's probably about equal
I don't know at some it's a bit this a
6b five is is an okay of alternative to
the normal
closed Sicilian but right here what has
lots of space computer gives equivalent
I don't really trust the engine ism I
mean here I don't run don't trust the
computer much it's just a normal opening
position that spirit undefined okay well
thanks for watching